[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Hello.
Welcome to lecture three of GD50.
Today, we're going be talking about
Match 3, as shown by the little cubes
here on the slide.
Match 3 originated a
little earlier than 2001,
but the first big game
that came out that was
a sort of genre staple of Match 3 was
Bejeweled, shown here on the screen.
This is a more modern
incarnation of Bejeweled,
but it came out originally in 2001.
It was actually a web browser game,
and the formula is very simple.
The premise is you have a grid of
different colored or shaped items,
usually pretty small, like
eight by eight, or so.
And your goal is just to simply, like
the name says, match three or more
of them in a row.
If you do, you get a
certain number of points.
Matching usually more than three
gives you more points, or a bonus.
And whenever you match three, the
blocks will disappear from the grid,
and they'll be replaced by more blocks.
And the ones that you made
holes for, the blocks above them
will come down via gravity.
This is a more modern
incarnation of the formula.
This is Candy Crush, which
I think most people know.
It was a very big hit on mobile devices,
and otherwise around 2013, 2012,
and that's probably the most recent
big Match 3 style game that's come out,
but there are a lot
of other takes on it--
different versions that try to
add new features, and stuff.
This is the game that we'll be putting
together today, and I'll show you how,
and we'll be covering a
few other things as well.
So the topics today,
we'll be covering, first
of all, a fundamental concept in dynamic
languages, a lot of dynamic languages,
and also Lua.
It's called anonymous
functions, which are functions
that are first class, meaning
that they operate as data types,
and so we can do some
fancy stuff with those.
Tweening, which means
just taking one thing,
and interpolating its value
between two values from 1,
to a destination value over time, which
is a very important thing in games.
You can do things like move objects.
We can also tween their opacity.
Just sort of asynchronous behavior,
and asynchronous variable manipulation.
Timers, very important.
We can time something to
happen at certain intervals,
or after a certain
length of time has passed
to get us past the idea of
storing different timed variables,
or different counters, and break
away, and keep timer objects that
will take care of this for us.
We'll see how we do that
with a specific library.
And then we'll get to the actual details
of Match 3, and how to solve matches,
and how to account for that.
Fill in the grid, account for
when we actually solve a match,
and repopulate it once we've done so.
We'll talk about how to
do this procedurally.
It's very simple compared to, I think,
Breakout's more procedural layout
system, but it's still randomisation,
and we'll talk about that.
And then last, if we have time,
we'll talk about sprite art,
and palettes, which is a big fundamental
thing when you're doing 2D game
development, and something that
this, and Breakout's sprite sheet
took advantage of was the idea of using,
on purpose, a restricted set of colors,
a palette for creating
your 2D art, and there
are a lot of really cool, and
impressive things we can do with that.
But first, I'd like to actually show
what we'll be running today in class.
So I'm going to come
here into my directory.
Make sure I'm in the
right place, which I am.
So this is part of the
distribution code, which is online.
So there's a Match 3 directory.
And would anybody like
to come demo it in class?
All right, [? Tony. ?] Come on up.
All right, so whenever you're ready,
go ahead, and just hit Return here.
[GAME MUSIC PLAYING]
All right, and so this is my
implementation of Match 3.
It uses a different set of tiles.
We have things that
are moving over time.
It's arrow key based.
So if you press Enter on any tile,
you can flip it with another tile.
It doesn't have to be
a match, in this case.
So you can-- yeah.
Yeah, you kind of got an unlucky board.
There, at the very bottom,
I see there's a few that--
some brown ones you can match together.
So once you match them together,
the tiles come down to repopulate.
You get new tiles up top.
And so notice, we have a
timer on the left as well.
It's something that's counting down.
We'll see how this is actually done with
the library we'll be using, as opposed
to managing a counter variable
keeping track of it over time.
A lot of games will actually implement
it so you have to-- you can only,
and this will be part of
the assignment, actually,
where you can only move a
tile if it creates a match.
In this case, there's a--
and we can see the timer counting
down, and then once you-- yeah,
if you don't get past the
goal, there's a game over.
But thanks, [? Tony. ?] I appreciate it.
AUDIENCE: No problem.
SPEAKER 1: So that's
the game in a nutshell.
And another thing I
want to point out to is
the transition, the white
transitions, and then the level text.
Those are all done with
timers that we'll be using,
and tweens, which we'll
be covering in class here
as some of our early examples.
But there's a lot of stuff that
we haven't touched on, but also
a lot that we have.
It uses sprites, and a sprite sheet,
and we've done that thing before.
We chop up a sprite sheet, and then
take out the whatever individual quads
you need, and draw them to the screen.
Here's what our goal is, which is
we have a title screen with Match 3,
start, and quit game in this case.
A little bit simpler.
No high scores this time just
because we've already covered that,
but we also have a level screen.
It tells us what level we're
on before we can actually play,
and there will be a transition
box with text in it.
It'll come down, stop,
and then come down again.
So almost like chain behavior, which
we'll see how we implement that too.
And then lastly, on the bottom
there is our main game screen,
where we have a level, a
score, and then a goal.
If you get the goal amount of
points before the timer runs out,
then you go to level 2,
and level 3, and level 4,
and the score increases by a
multiplied factor each time.
So the first thing I'd like
to start talking about today
is how we actually get timer behavior
using something a little bit more
than just keeping track of
some variable that we set to 0,
and then adding dt to it every update.
There's a better way to do
that, but first, why don't we
go ahead, and look at timer0.
And so what I'm going to do is
go into the timer0 directory.
I'm going run it, and we can see
here, in the middle of the screen,
just a very simple--
just a label that just says
timer, and then x seconds,
where obviously the x is
incrementing over time every second.
So a crude way, what would be
an easy way to implement this?
AUDIENCE: Do you like [INAUDIBLE] random
in Flappy Bird [INAUDIBLE] randomizer
[INAUDIBLE] if you just keep
track of your delta prime
and add it to some variable outside
[INAUDIBLE] you do something else?
You could even just display
the variable [INAUDIBLE]..
SPEAKER 1: Yes.
So the response was keep some variable
that you modify with dt in update,
or display the variable.
Yeah, that's definitely a way.
Did you have--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I was just going
to say, keep a float variable,
and constantly add a dt
to it, and display it,
but display the truncated version.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
So keep a float variable, but just
truncate the delta time off of it.
You could do that, definitely.
We'll take a look here as
to actually how I did do it.
It's very similar to that.
This is the wrong directory, though.
So it's in timer0 in main.
So we do have a variable.
So the current second here, which we
are going to keep track of 0, 1, 2.
Lua doesn't really have the
notion of truncate a float
because when you take a
number that's floating point,
and you make it into
a string, you actually
have to do string
substitution on it where
you use a function called g sub
to take off the last part manually
because it doesn't really
differentiate between ints and floats.
It just has a number data type.
But we can do this by
just keeping track of
whether or not we've passed
a certain length of time
because we know dt is
given to us in seconds.
We can just add to our variable,
and then every time we've
gone over 1, because it gives us--
it gives you usually like .013, whatever
1/60 or approximately 1/60 of a second
is.
Once our timer-- we're going to
keep a timer variable-- equals 1,
we'll just increment
current second by 1,
and then we'll set that
timer back to 0, and then
we'll just repeat over, and over again.
We'll actually use modulus so in
case we go slightly over 1 second,
we can account for that.
We do that here.
So second timer gets second
timer plus delta time,
and then if it's greater than 1.
So if a full second has elapsed,
just increment current second,
and then modulo a second timer by 1.
And Lua is a little different
in that most languages only let
you modulo something if it's an integer,
but since there is no differentiation,
you can actually modulo
floats, and you'll
get the floating point value leftover.
And so that's the basic
way of actually doing that,
but there's a couple of
things wrong with it.
So does anybody want to suggest what
is potentially bad or unscalable
about this kind of approach?
Well, I'll show you
timer1 so we can maybe
get a sense of how this could kind
of get out of hand pretty quickly.
So let's say-- first, I'll run timer1.
So let's go into timer1 here, and
notice now we have five labels.
They're running at different intervals.
The first timer, it's
incrementing every 1 second,
the second timer is
incrementing every 4 seconds,
the third one is incrementing every 4
seconds, and then so on, 3, and then 2.
So if we wanted to do the same
approach that we just did,
this is what we would do.
We have five variables, five timers.
Because we want to keep
track of whether or not
something's gone over
more than just one second,
it's not super easy to just
put this all in a table,
and iterate over it, and use
your iteration logic to do that.
We actually, because they're in some
sort of random, who knows what order,
timer2 takes 2 seconds, OK, timer3 takes
4 seconds, timer4 takes 3, and then 2,
you have to unmanageably keep all
of this in separate variables.
[? Yes, Tony ?]
AUDIENCE: Couldn't you just use one
second timer, or even one variable,
and then just in the display [INAUDIBLE]
SPEAKER 1: You could.
Yeah, in this case, you could.
Again, Lua's display, it's a
little bit funky when you--
you have to do g sub, and
some weird string stuff,
but yes, you could do that.
AUDIENCE: Couldn't you just do modulo
1, and then take that value as a string?
Is that the equivalent of truncating?
SPEAKER 1: Modulo 1 would still
give you the floating point value
because there's only one number type.
So if we modulo 1.00157
by 1, we'd get 0.00157.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
OK.
If you subtracted from that
value, from I don't know.
So it's a value minus the
value of modulo 1, I guess.
SPEAKER 1: So yeah.
It was proposed that we've
used modulo, and we could.
In short, we could, but
what if we're not just
printing a value to the screen.
What if we have 10 different things,
like 10 different creatures that
are all doing different
things over time,
and we don't necessarily want to
have to keep a timer for each,
and every one of those things.
In a simple example like this,
yeah, there's probably a--
on purpose, it's also a
little bit convoluted just
to illustrate the problem.
But yes, there are shortcuts for
this, but the fundamental problem
is how can we get rid of having
five different timers for something?
And by the way, I'll
go to the next slide.
Timer0, the simple way.
Timer1, the ugly way.
Timer2 is the clean way that
I found using this ecosystem.
There's a wonderful library, and
you could implement this yourself.
The fundamental idea
is have a global timer
object that then manages all
of these different things going
on using the power of what I alluded
to earlier, anonymous functions,
and I'll show you how that works.
So in main.lua of timer2,
we have a set of intervals.
We have a set of counters.
And then what we're doing here is
we're just saying for i gets 1 to 5,
we're calling a function
call timer.every.
So if you're familiar with
JavaScript programming,
there's a set interval
function which lets
you do something every length of time.
So first of all, timer
is just a library.
We've just required it here.
It's part of the knife
ecosystem, and then
here, we have a couple of functions,
timer.every, and timer.after
that we'll use.
Well, basically, what
it does is you give it
a length of time-- timer.every seconds.
It's in seconds, and you can
give it fractional seconds.
You're passing in just a function
here, just an anonymous function.
It doesn't have a name, but because
Lua, and a lot of dynamic languages
treat functions as first
class citizens, as it
called, because they are data types,
you can just pass them into functions.
This allows us to do behavior
like this that would otherwise
be a little bit tricky to do.
We can just say after
this block of time,
assuming we've built some structure
that is probably just storing
a table with a bunch of things
that have a length of time in them,
just call this block of code later.
It's called a callback function.
We're just going to call it back,
and then we're just going to do this.
We're going to say counters
i gets counters i plus 1.
So we have all of these intervals,
and all of these counters.
So it will just, basically,
manage that for us,
and now we don't have five variables.
You do have to set whatever
you want those to be.
That's your that's your
primitive at this point.
You just need the lengths of
time, depending on your problem.
In this case, that's all we need.
You might need more than that, depending
on what you want to do with timer.
But in this case, we just want
to increment in value over time.
So keep counters, and then just
keep track of the intervals,
and then our code's gone from
I don't know how many lines.
It was a lot larger--
I think was 96 lines, down
to 98 lines, down to 70,
and this is incredibly scalable.
If we wanted to add another
one that's 8 for example,
we just need to add 8, and then that.
I guess I'd have to do this as well.
I gets 5 to 6, and then you want
to-- the computer that requires me
to off my user so I can make changes.
We'll just real quickly
see if I didn't mess up.
And so yeah, basically we're
deferring everything to timer now.
We get the exact same behavior,
but a much smaller length of code.
And the nice thing is
it's very declarative.
We can just say OK, every something
seconds, I want this chunk of behavior
to happen.
I don't have to see OK, I've got
timers up here, I've got counters here.
OK, down in my draw function,
OK, I've got to draw all these.
It's iterative, and it's declarative,
and that's the ultimate goal.
And here, at the very
bottom, it did actually work.
Now it's working every eight
seconds, which is nice.
One, two, there we go.
Super easy to extend.
We're going to be using it
a lot in this problem set,
and also in future lectures just
because it's a lot easier than keeping
track of a bunch of counter variables.
And there's another function
that we're seeing here--
timer.after because sometimes you just
want to wait a certain length of time.
Maybe you have every 1 second for
5 seconds you want a bomb to tick,
and then after 5 seconds,
you want it to blow up,
and you could also model that with
another function that we'll see soon,
but these are probably the
two core time-based functions.
And you can go here to this URL
able to see the knife library.
There's a bunch of modules
that are really nice.
We just happen to be
using timer, and it's
tween, and every after functions
primarily in this problem.
But we'll use another one called the
event in the Zelda [? p-set, ?] where
we actually look at how to dispatch
events, and triggers, and stuff,
and to prevent us from
checking every frame.
Oh, what do we have to do?
If some wall is broken,
this frame, then do this.
We can just dispatch an
event that we blow up a wall.
We'll get to that.
Any questions at all about how those
two models differ, and how they work?
OK, cool.
So the next thing I want to look at--
so we can tie that back into also,
real quick, if we want.
Match 3-- whoops, and then
there's a timer that's
manipulating the text on the screen.
All of those letters in the-- this is
in the start state of the game code.
All of those letters have a
color associated with them,
but they're on a timer so that
after every 0.075 seconds,
they'll go to another
color, and to another color.
And so we don't have to
keep track of every letter's
individual color, and a timer for it.
We can just change them all.
If we start the game, something
else that's on a timer, the timer,
actually, there, which is
just decrementing some value.
Every one second, decrement
timer by 1, and that's it,
and we don't have to keep any-- we don't
have to say anything more than just
that, and that's what's really nice
about using that kind of model.
So another thing that you probably
also noticed, and I'll run it again,
is this fade out, and fade
in, and also that animation.
Those are things that
are happening over time.
We don't actually-- we can
just sort of manipulate them.
We can keep track of some
sort of counter for it.
We can also just say over this length of
time, change this value to this value,
and that's a much easier way
to model the problem mentally.
And so we'll illustrate that.
First, I'm going to go to tween0.
So tween0 is the simple
way to do something.
So I'm going to illustrate tweening
here with Flappy Bird just going
left to right.
So up there, that's what happens when
you print out the number, by the way,
just by default.
And so if you wanted to
truncate it, yeah, you
could just g sub the first two, I
guess, depending on how large it is,
and that would have the effect of
displaying it as just an integer.
But we can see that over
two seconds, we've had--
and there's a little bit of
overlap just because delta time can
go a little bit over two seconds when
you're adding to it because it just
adds whatever length of time as a
float has elapsed since the last frame.
In this case, we're just adding it
until it's greater than or equal to 2.
So in this case, we went 0.01 over
2 by the time that actually ended.
Some iterations will be less than that.
So this one will be--
yeah, see, that one was less than 2.01.
It just depends on your
computer, and your specs.
But Flappy Bird starts on the very left.
So he's got an x-coordinate,
and then at the very end,
he's got another x-coordinate.
So the simple solution is what?
We know that we want this
to elapse over two seconds.
So what we can do is I'm
going to pull up tween0.
And MOVE_DURATION here, it's
a constant of 2 seconds just
for the sake of this example.
A sprite here, just a simple image.
I'm putting everything in one code file
this time, as opposed to breaking it
out into subclasses just for simplicity
because these are such small examples.
But we're setting it's x and y.
Oh, and this is another
Lua trick, by the way.
You can assign two variables to
two values using a comma here.
So flappyX comma flappyY gets
0, and then VIRTUAL_HEIGHT
divided by 2 minus 8.
Setting this x to 0, we have a
timer here, and then it's end x.
So we want it to end at
the end of the screen.
So we're going to say virtual
width minus his width, an then
the usual boilerplate for
getting a project set to go.
If it's less than the move duration--
so if timer is 0 going up to 2,
but it's not quite 2 yet, we're going to
add dt to it, and then we're going to,
basically, assign it to
either the lowest of end x,
so it will never go higher than end
x, or end x times the ratio of timer
over move duration.
So timer over move duration,
if it's less than 2,
that's going to be some value,
some fractional amount less than 1.
So it's going to
basically just scale it,
depending on how far we've
moved the timer between 0 and 2.
So just a scaling operation.
This happens to only work in the context
of moving something from left to right,
or from 0 to something else, but it's
a crude, basic way of illustrating
a very basic tween operation.
That's what it essentially is.
It's a multiplier of some ratio
of how much time has passed,
versus how much time we're
actually looking to elapse.
And that has the effect,
once again, of just--
it's scaling the ratio because
it's timer over moved duration.
It's something over 2, but
it's not quite 2 over 2.
Until it gets 2 over 2, and it's 1,
then end x times 1 is going to be end x.
But before that, it's going to be some
fraction of end x between 0 and end x.
So it has the effect of giving us a very
basic tween, but it's a little bit--
we have a little bit to manage here.
It doesn't really feel super clean.
Do you guys have any questions
about how this works?
OK.
So we're going to go here.
So first of all, any thoughts about
how that might not be super scalable,
looking back at the last example?
AUDIENCE: I guess like
the situation before,
getting a lot of objects
moving on the screen.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, and what if your index
is different for every single one?
Then you have kind of a mess.
What if we had something like this?
You don't want to keep
track of an end to x.
They all happened to
have the same end x,
but notice they're moving
at different rates.
They're all moving at some
sort of random amount.
AUDIENCE: How many are there?
SPEAKER 1: There's 1,000.
We could go crazier if we wanted.
This is a fun thing to
do, is stress testing.
So if I go to tween1, and I
go to main, timer max is 10.
So we're saying that the
longest possible time
any bird can take to get from left
to right is going be 10 seconds.
So right here, we're using
a table based approach here.
We're actually keeping track of
1,000 birds, and we're saying,
OK, here's an empty
table from 1 to 1,000.
Add a new bird, and in this case, we're
not adding a bird object, or anything.
It's just a table.
They all start x equals 0, left side.
Their y is random.
So they can be anywhere between the
top and the bottom of the screen.
So VIRTUAL_HEIGHT minus 24.
24 happens to be the
height of the sprite,
and I should have probably put
Flappy sprite get height right there.
And then rate, they're all
going to have their own rate.
So rate gets math.random.
Math.random without a
value passed into it
gives you a fractional value
between 0 and 0.999999.
What this has the effect of doing
is math.random with just two values,
if you pass in 10 and 50, it's
going to give you 10 to 50,
but they're always going
to be integer values.
You can't say like 10.0 and
50.0, and assume that it
will know what you're talking about.
It's just going to be integers.
So if you give it one
value, it will know.
OK, you're asking me for a
float between 0 and 0.999999.
That's going to act as the
fractional part of whatever value we
might want to generate using a
math.random with a value passed in.
So here, we're saying OK,
math.random, TIMER_MAX minus 1.
So TIMER_MAX is 9.
So our TIMER_MAX is 10, sorry.
So if we subtract 1 from
that, this is math.random 10.
So we're going to get a
value between 1 and 9.
So TIMER_MAX minus 1 is 9.
Sorry if I said 10.
TIMER_MAX is 10, TIMER_MAX
minus 1 is 9, but we're
adding math.random,
some fractional amount.
So whatever value we choose between 1--
actually between--
yeah, between 1 and 9,
it's going to be that
value, point something.
So this is how you get random--
basically, at the end
of the day, this is
how you get random floating
point numbers in Lua and Love2D.
Does that make sense?
Do you guys have questions about that?
AUDIENCE: So your final rate
could be anywhere from 0 to--
SPEAKER 1: Final rate is going to be
anywhere from 1-- in this case from,
1 to 9.999999.
If we wanted it to be
0, we could do that,
and that'll give us the effect of taking
whatever we get, and subtracting 1.
So now it will be
between 0 and 8.999999.
And if we did this--
AUDIENCE: Couldn't each
math.random end up at 0?
SPEAKER 1: No, because math.random,
if you pass in a value,
it'll always do from 1 to some value.
The question was will math.random
give you 0 if you pass in a value?
And math.random, by default, gives
you between 1 and something else.
And so that's why we do this.
That's not why we do this.
We do this to add the fractional
part so that we can get
fractional floats between some value.
But yeah, if you wanted it to be
between 0, and something else,
you would just subtract
1 from the final result
because we know that we're always
going to get from 1 to some value.
If you minus from 1, you
will never go below 0.
It will always be 0 to something
else, and then in that case,
we probably would just
take off the minus 1
from TIMER_MAX so that it will be
between 0 and 9.999999 in this case.
But as a design decision, I
made it so that we would always
have at least a rate
of 1 because then it
could get really, really slow if it's
like 0.005 or something like that.
You wouldn't want that.
It would take ages.
OK, so we have a timer.
We're not using knife.timer
in this case yet.
Basically, in update, we're just saying
as long as timer max is less than--
timer is less than timer max.
This update logic will only run as
long as we haven't gone over timer max.
Increment it, and then for
each bird, basically, we're
doing the same thing that we
did before, except we're using
that bird's rate as the scale factor.
Yeah, the denominator
of that ratio, and that
will have the effect of
multiplying all of those birds
individually, based on
their own rate, rather than
some global rate, if that makes sense.
And then here, we're just drawing
all of them at their own x and y.
And just again, we're just
storing birds are just
a table with a few
variables in this case.
Just a very simple shell,
and it has the effect of--
oh, and one thing I wanted
to do is just add a 0 there.
I've got to do this every
time because I didn't
set my permissions appropriately.
But now there's going
to be 10,000 birds.
So let's see how this looks.
So it looks pretty similar, actually,
but it's a little more condensed now.
I don't notice a frame rate drop.
If we wanted, we could go down to
love.draw, and love.graphics.printf
at FPS, and then to string,
love.timer.getFPS, and then
let's set it to 4, and then
VIRTUAL_HEIGHT minus 16,
and then got to do this again.
This should have the effect
of giving us our frame rate.
So we can really stress test
this, and see what the--
oh.
I made a mistake.
OK, let's see.
What did I do?
Push.start.
I'm guessing I missed a--
yeah, I missed a--
do that, and then that,
and then save it again.
Sorry about that.
There won't be too many of
these edits, but I figured
this would be fun to illustrate.
So now, this should work.
Printf, so we have that.
Oh, right, and then it
just needs to be print.
It doesn't need to be printf.
Got to save again.
Sorry.
This will be worth it, I hope.
There we go, 5160.
OK, it takes a couple of seconds.
It has to interpolate between
the last couple of times
that it's pulled for frames,
and when you start up,
it doesn't have the data it needs.
So 10,000, easy.
Let's do like a million.
So we have 10,000, 100,000, a million.
I really got to change
those permissions.
Getting good at practicing
my password, though.
Going to go ahead, and do that.
Ooh.
Oh, my laptop is suffering.
Oh man, but they're all moving
independent of frame rate.
This is just a testament to
how powerful delta time is.
They all move there after 10 seconds.
We've got to 10.6 seconds,
which is not good.
That means that's how long
passed between the last frame,
but my laptop clearly can not handle
a million birds on the screen,
but it can handle 10,000,
or maybe even 100,000.
And that's just a fun way--
a fun thing to do.
In general, when you want
to stress test your game,
just put the frames per
second on, and just go nuts.
Just add a lot of stuff.
Just see what your computer
is capable of because you
can find new, fun things that
way, I guess, and maybe just
see how good your code is too.
So tween0, simple way.
We have just variables, and one counter.
No tables or anything.
Tween2 is a good way for
if we have a lot of things
that we want to manipulate over time.
But what if now we want
some of them to change
their opacity over time or something?
It starts to get a little
bit more complicated.
And this is, by the way, I should've
put this earlier in the code,
but this is the knife library
is responsible for timer,
and a lot of other things
that we'll be looking at,
and it's got a bunch of
modules here listed--
behavior for state
machines, which is like what
we've been doing for state machines,
but they have their own version of it.
Knife.bind, so you can pre-bind
arguments to functions,
and create subfunction.
It's called currying, but create
subfunctions of other functions
that have pre-determined variables.
Knife.chain, we'll see, actually,
how that can be used coming up later.
Convoke is for coroutines.
We'll see coroutines in
the context of Unity,
but basically, they're functions
that can pause their state for later.
Knife.event we'll use
in two weeks for Zelda,
maybe even next week if I
can fit it in for Mario.
Memoize is for memoization.
It's like a dynamic
programming related thing.
Serialized system.
System is going to be useful to know
about in context of Unity as well.
Unity uses an entity component
system for much of its structure.
Knife.test, and then
lastly, knife.timer,
which is what we'll end up using, and
this is probably my favorite library
that exists in the Love2D ecosystem.
And so with that said,
we'll look at tween2 now.
I'm going to go here into tween2, and so
now we have not just movement, but also
their opacity.
They all start at
different opacity levels,
and we want to not only
change their movement
over time, but also the opacity.
So it would get a little
bit trickier if we decided
to do that with our current situation.
Totally doable, but how would we
go about changing, just right now,
their opacity just as is?
How do you change a spite's opacity?
AUDIENCE: The variable and
the graphics [INAUDIBLE]
SPEAKER 1: Is it a variable--
can you say that one more time?
AUDIENCE: I forget the
exact function name,
but it's like love.graphics
to put an image on the screen.
SPEAKER 1: The love.graphics.draw.
AUDIENCE: Wasn't there
an argument in that?
SPEAKER 1: So it's actually not
an argument to that function.
So I'll show you now.
So in order to draw something
at some different opacity,
it's actually love.graphics.setcolor,
and we do that here.
So recall that Love2D is a state
machine, and how it draws things.
You can basically set
a color onto anything
that you draw, whether it's
a font, an image, or a shape.
And if you just pass in
255, 255, 255, that's white.
And then if you give
it an opacity, which
is the fourth parameter, which
is the alpha component of that,
then that's how transparent it will be.
And so we could have done
this with other colors too.
We could have done this with
like if we wanted to tint it red,
and also have it be sort of transparent.
We could do that if we just
did 25500 bird.opacity.
But if you just want to manipulate
opacity independent of--
or its transparency or its
alpha independent of its color,
and keep it the same exact
color, you just do it white.
If you did it black,
nothing would show up.
Is that true, actually?
Let me verify that.
Pretty sure that's right,
but I could be wrong.
I'm right, thankfully.
OK.
That or they're just black, and
there's a black background too.
Do you have a question, [? Tony? ?]
AUDIENCE: No.
SPEAKER 1: Oh, OK.
So we'll take it on faith
that that is correct.
And back to the gist of this example.
We have TIMER_MAX again.
Actually, we really
haven't changed much.
What we have changed is
we still have our birds.
We need to keep track of their
x, of their y, of their rate.
Well, not necessarily their rate.
Oh, well, their rate, yeah,
because we're actually
going to loop over each
of these, and then create
a timer between operations for them.
And their opacity.
Oh right, they start
with an opacity of 0,
and faded to 55, regardless of their--
their opacity changes at the
same rate as their x does.
So the farther away,
the longer they take,
the slower they fade to fully
opaque, and we see this here.
So for k bird and pairs of birds.
So for every bird, we're just going to
set a tween, and then this is tween.
So timer.tween is I think I
have a slide on it here, right?
A super cool useful function,
super easy to use too, it
takes iteration just like timer.every,
timer.after, and it takes a definition.
So in this case, it doesn't
take an anonymous function
like the other ones did
because we're not really
saying I want to do some
sort of undefined behavior
over the course of this operation.
What I want to do is
just change some values.
I want to interpolate them.
So what we're going to do is just
pass in a-- this is the syntax for it.
We pass in square brackets, the
actual thing that we want to change.
In this case, I want to change bird.
I want bird to change
in some way, and then
what I want it's values to
change toward are these.
I want it's x to change to end x,
and I want it's opacity to go to 255.
And I wanted to do it over
bird.rate, and so this bird.rate,
every bird is storing it.
So for birds that got
a rate of 2, then it's
x is going to go to end x
over the course of 2 seconds,
and it's opacity is going to go to
255 over the course of 2 seconds.
And you can put as many things
as you want, and as many--
you can put as many variables
here, and as many entities.
Entities being anything
that you want to change that
has a field, any table-based
or class-based structure.
You can pass any of those in here,
and just tween them all at the same--
if they all have the same rate, and
then just get that operation that way.
And so that has the effect here
of all we need to do is just add--
it's like two lines of code, but
now we've easily changed it so
that we can just tween
two things at once,
and that's the power of
timer.tween, and we'll see that.
So back to, actually, Match 3,
if we want to look at that again.
This is a tween, that's a tween,
that's a tween, and that's a tween.
So the white, the foreground
there, is just a rectangle
that fills the whole screen.
It's just a white rectangle.
I have it set to timer.tween
opacity from 0 to 255.
Before that gets called, if we go from
the start to the begin game state,
and then if we go from at the
beginning of the game state,
before the level text comes
down, it's going from 255 to 0.
So it's just the reverse of that is
the tween, and then all it's doing
is just drawing a
rectangle to the screen.
But that's how you get a
very simple transition.
Same thing for fade to black.
If you want to fade the
whole screen to black,
just draw a rectangle
the size of the screen,
and then just tween its opacity
from 0 to 255, and then vise versa.
That's how you get a simple transition.
It can be any color you want.
It can be a red transition.
And then the level text, that's
just a tween on the y, right?
And then I just have some rectangle,
love.graphics.rectangle with text,
and it just says timer.tween to like
VIRTUAL_HEIGHT divided by 2 minus 8,
and then timer.after1.
So we can actually pull
this up if we want.
We can see how this works.
Today's going to be a little
wider on the main distro code
just because a lot of
this is more conceptual.
But in the begin game state--
well, actually, in the start state
is when we go.
So these colors, and letter table, and
stuff that's all for the Match 3 text,
if you're curious.
So these are all back to what I said
earlier about the beginning screen
having Match 3 with the different
colors going on a timer.
These are just tables of colors.
So notice this is RGBA, and
then I'm just performing
a shuffle on them every 0.075 seconds.
So 2 will get 1, and vise versa.
It'll all go down, and then 6 will
come up here to 1 every 0.75 seconds.
And then M gets mapped to this
one, A gets mapped to this one,
T to this one, C, H, 3, and that's it.
That's done here at line
44 of the start state.
But what I was going to show you
was the tween for the transitions.
So here in start state, in
the update function says,
it says if we press Enter,
and our current menu item
is 1, meaning that we're on start
game, not quit game, timer.tween here.
And notice that we have a finish
function, which will show--
I'm actually going to show you in the
next couple of examples, the chain
examples.
But finish is just a
function that you can
run after any timer that just
says, hey, when this is finished,
run this block of code, and notice
that takes anonymous function here,
just like that.
So we can say OK, tween, over
the course of one second,
notice we're passing self into here
because we want to manipulate ourself.
We have a value that
we want to manipulate.
So self.transitionAlpha.
So we're saying I want to
take my transition alpha,
and I want it to go to 255, and we set
it to 0 by default. So at the very top,
here, at line 60, transition alpha
is just our white rectangle that
fills the screen.
I'm just saying set it to 0
so we don't see it at all.
It's going to be invisible.
It's still there no matter what.
It's hidden, but after
we press Enter, tween
it to 255 over the course of 1
second, and then when that's finished,
notice this is familiar, right?
gStateMachine change begin game.
We're going to go with the
begin game state after that.
Our passing level gets 1.
We're starting the game, and then
we're going to remove this color.
Remove that timer from
the-- this is actually
unnecessary in this circumstance,
but you can remove timers from timer.
If you have something going constantly--
in this case, the color timer, and
let's say we move from this state
to the next state, the next state
doesn't have all those colors,
right, the Match 3 colors.
So we don't need to keep--
because timer is a global object,
it's going to keep updating
over, and over again.
We don't need certain timers
to exist indefinitely.
We can just remove this one
because it's not relevant anymore.
But this is all it takes just to give
us a simple transition from one screen
to another.
Just give this transition alpha 255
down in the actual render function.
Where is it?
It is right here.
So right here.
Draw our transition rect.
It's going to be drawn last so that it
draws over everything when we finally
do get a transition, but
self.transitionAlpha,
and that's all we really need.
We need to keep the
variable, and then whenever
we want to perform like some
sort of operation over time,
just use timer.tween.
It's that easy.
But that was a little bit of a--
it was a relevant tangent.
We would have talked about it
anyway, but that's the first use case
that I think of in this project,
and then also the label.
I'll show you the label in a little bit.
But I think before we do that,
let's talk about chaining.
So you guys have probably
played a lot of games
where maybe there's a cut scene,
and you're looking at a character,
and they walk, and then maybe they turn,
and they walk in another direction,
and they walk up, and
then they speak to you.
There's a dialog box, and then maybe
they do an animation or something,
and then maybe some other
things happen that are
on some sort of predestined path.
It's a very discrete path.
It's not random.
It's laid out in advance.
It's a series of steps, one consecutive.
That's the concept of chaining
things together is relevant
when we get to sort of timing
things because when we finish timing
something-- because usually,
a lot of those things
happen over the course of time.
Over the course of five seconds,
NPC1 will walk up north,
and then they'll turn left,
and then they'll say something.
We want to model that.
We don't want to basically
have variables that say
if NPC1 is at this tile, then do this.
If NPC.dialogueOpen, then do this.
We basically want to say
walk here, do this, do this,
do this in a flat, easy-- or at least
semi-flat, easy sequence of steps.
I have a few examples to illustrate
how we can do that using timer
for some semi-basic use cases.
So chain0 is the first one.
So this one is just Flappy Bird.
He's going left to right, then he goes
down, then he goes back left again,
and then he goes up.
What's the basic way
that we model this--
that we implement this?
Just off the cuff.
AUDIENCE: We can use that
finish thing to do the--
SPEAKER 1: We would.
If we didn't know about finish,
how would we probably do it?
I shouldn't have given away finish
before I got to that example.
I kind of got ahead of myself.
We can imagine somebody
maybe saying OK, I
want Flappy to move left to right,
right to bottom, bottom to left,
bottom to up.
Maybe they're going to say
if Flappy is less than--
or has reached first point, move left,
else if he's reached bottom or point 2,
move down, and then move left, move up.
And in both of those cases, they're
changing the x and y value of Flappy,
and it's basically just a lot
of ifs, and state variables.
I see it in a surprising amount of code.
Just state being kept
all over the place.
The first implementation of that that
we'll look at uses something similar.
So in chain0, and there's only two
examples here, actually, for chain.
But chain0, there's a movement
time, and then a timer.
We're going to be semi-clean about it.
We have some destinations.
OK, so we have destination1.
I know that I don't necessarily want to
keep track of a bunch of if statements,
but I'm going for--
assuming that I don't know
what timer can do for us,
here, I'm just saying OK, I
want this first destination
to be virtual width
minus his width, and then
keep him at y0 So right edge of the
screen, assuming that he starts at 0,0.
And then I want his second destination
to be that same side on the x-axis,
but I want the y to be virtual
height minus his height.
So go to the bottom of the screen.
Then I want it to be 0 in his height
from the bottom of the screen,
and then back to 0,0.
So we have those modeled, and then I
want to keep a flag in each of those.
I want to know whether he's
reached that state yet.
So I'm going to iterate over
that table I just created,
and just add a new key to
each of these called reached,
and just set it to false.
Just by default, he hasn't
reached all of them yet.
And then in the update,
basically, I'm going
to set a timer to the
min of movement time.
So it will never go higher than movement
time, and then timer plus delta time.
And then for every destination in
destinations, if it wasn't reached,
then set its x and y, FlappyX and
FlappyY, which are, in this case,
we're uncleanly using global
variables to keep track of this.
FlappyX and FlappyY gets baseX.
So notice another problem.
We have to maintain where we are
relative to our next spot in order
for this math to work because
before, we just took Flappy Birds--
basically, the timer
divided by movement time
was a ratio where we
scaled the end destination,
and assigned that to Flappy,
which had the effect of moving
Flappy left to right.
But if we do that in the
opposite, right to left,
the math isn't the same
because he's going backwards.
He's getting negative
values added to his x value.
So we need to keep track of a
base that he started at for each
of these operations baseX, baseY.
So at the very beginning,
baseX, baseY is 0,0.
So it's actually going
to be much the same,
but as soon as Flappy get to
the right edge of the screen,
we want baseX to be the right
edge of the screen, baseY still 0,
and then if he goes down, we want baseY
to then be bottom edge of the screen,
baseX to be right edge, and so forth.
So what we do is we just scale.
We're still using a timer over
movement time as our scale factor,
but we're adding the difference
of our destination and our base,
and we're multiplying by
that scale factor instead.
And so this difference, if
we add it, whether we're
moving left, or right,
or down, or up, it's
going to have the effect of filling
in that gap of bridging that no matter
where we are, no matter which
direction we want to go.
And so this is basically a fairly
complete linear interpolation
algorithm, which is
the basis of tweening.
Just interpolate some value
between another value.
It's usually modeled in geometry
as the line between two segments.
And then if timer gets
movement time, we've
reached our destination, reset
the timer, reset or baseX and Y,
and that has the effect of just doing
what we saw earlier, which was just
putting him point by point.
So any questions as to how
this interpolation-- how
this way of modeling the problem works?
All right, so there is a better way, a
much better way thanks to timer.finish,
which you can apply to any timer
operation, including timer.tween.
So we can basically say OK, once that
operation is finished, do something.
And this is all we have to do,
we just have to say timer.tween.
We no longer have to interpolate at all.
That's taken care of for us by timer.
So we're doing timer.tween
over movement time.
Flappy, set it to-- this was before we
add all this in a destinations table
with reached flags as well.
Now, we just have the x and y here.
So on the first movement, we want
his x to be right edge of the screen,
just like before-- y get zero.
Once that's finished, anonymous
function with another timer.tween.
So we're saying OK,
once you're finished,
then tween him from the top right
edge to the bottom right edge.
So y gets VIRTUAL_HEIGHT
minus FlappySprite getHeight.
And then once that's finished,
another anonymous function,
another timer.tween, another
finish, another anonymous function,
another timer.tween.
And this is, in its own way, unscalable.
It's nested.
There's a term for it
called call back hell
because you just get infinite downwards
sloping anonymous functions with all
this behavior.
There are ways to flatten it, and
we potentially will talk about it.
It's part of knife.chain.
Knife.chain has a way
to turn all of these--
basically, it would look
something like this.
It would be chain, and then it
would be like moveFlappy x, y.
MoveFlappy x2-- it wouldn't be x2, y2.
We'd actually write these out here, but
it would have the exact same effect.
This is if you're looking to maybe
implement a cut scene system, or just
some sort of scripting
system for your game
that's very declarative,
and imperative in style.
This is the holy grail of changing
behavior, and getting it to work,
and just making it look
nice, and readable.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Well, you could also pass in--
you could pass in a table to your
function of x's and y's [INAUDIBLE]
simpler for [INAUDIBLE]
to chain a lot of things.
SPEAKER 1: Yes, you could do that too.
The response was you
could pass in a table to--
you could iterate over a
table, and within that table,
generate a timer.tween.
The only issue comes about with
finish, and there is a way--
I guess you could get a
reference back to the timer,
and then add a finish block to it,
but then you would lose out on--
that does work for the same
function if all you're doing
is moving something to a bunch of
locations, it's absolutely true.
But if we wanted Flappy say something,
and hero disappear, and then
hero flash, it gets a little bit
trickier to do stuff like that.
But yes, I agree.
There are ways of modeling-- this
particular example is a little bit
repetitive, and could be
modeled, I think, better
with a function that takes
advantage of the fact
that timers can be returned, and
then given new finish variables.
I'd have to experiment with it
to see because I'm actually not
100% sure that you can add a finish.
No, I think you can, actually.
I think you can add a finish
function to a reference
because it's just a
function on an object.
So yeah, but independent of
that, I think the goal probably
is one, knowing how we can now
chain behavior, and then two,
striving towards flattening it.
But in the purpose of this problem
set, we'll see this a couple of times,
and it's just worlds better than before.
What's this, 76 lines?
And then tween1 or chain0 was 96.
OK, so 20 lines of code.
And also the fact that now we have
a declarative interface for modeling
asynchronous behavior, that's
really the fundamental thing,
is not having some value that models
your duration, or your counter,
or whatever value, but just saying,
hey, over this length of time,
I want you to do this.
I want to do this.
After this length of time,
I want you to do this.
I always like to try and strive towards
making code as declarative as possible
just so that you can
read it in the future,
and then the people
working on your code base
can also read it well
in the future, and I
think timer does a pretty
awesome job of that.
And this is just a
reference for timer finish.
So it just takes a callback,
and then once a timer function
tween every or after has completed,
it triggers that callback.
So we're going to take a break for five
minutes now, and then once we get back,
we'll talk about swapping, and some
of the algorithms we use in Match 3,
starting with just rendering a board,
getting tiles to swap, tweening them,
and then we'll actually look
at how we take falling tiles,
and account for them,
and then repopulate them.
All right, we're back.
So recall, before break
we were looking at timer,
and how to take code that was previously
managed by timers, and asynchronous,
but also very stateful, and sort
of messy, and all over the place,
and putting it into a
more declarative, clean,
easy to express format via timer.tween,
timer.every, timer.after, timer.finish,
timer;finish for any timer objects.
So with all that out
of the way, now we'll
start talking about the
actual Match 3 mechanics.
And the very first thing
that we'll look at is swap0,
and this is the sprite sheet for
Match 3 that's included in the distro.
So as we can see, it's something that we
can easily chop up with generate quads,
as we saw before.
Just a function provided in util.lua.
These are all 32 by 32 pixels.
So it would be very easy just
to go through all of them,
and basically just generate quads
with the sprite sheet 32, 32,
and just get a table with all
of these individual things.
But notice that they're blocked
up into patterns of colors,
and this has actual meaning,
and value for our game
because when something
is the same color,
and only when something is the same
color, a tile is the same color,
are we allowed to
trigger a match with it.
If we get any three or four--
anything higher than three
together in a line, vertically
or horizontally, that's a match, and
we need to remove it from the table.
So we need some sort of way of
identifying these tiles as being
of some color, and then they also happen
to have a different pattern on them.
This one's got nothing, but then an
x, and then a circle, and a square.
So those patterns-- it's not
implemented in the distro,
but part of the assignment.
It's actually going
to make them relevant.
But the part that is implemented is
the actual matching of the colors.
And so the first thing that we'll
need to do, probably, when we actually
get into the core code
of the distribution
is instead of just putting them
into one table, categorizing them.
Splitting it up into maybe one, two,
three, four, five, six, seven, eight,
nine times two--
18 tables, so that we can
just say gframes at color.
So color being one to 18, and
then get the index into that.
So there's six within each one.
So it'll be one to six.
One to six will be the variety,
with one being the base variety.
And part of the assignment
will be make sure
that the base variety is the only
one that we start with on level one,
but then gradually introduce
these other varieties.
And you can put them
in whatever hierarchy
you want to, but make them
have some sort of value
later on top of a few other
things the assignment will cover.
But that's the
spreadsheet in a nutshell,
and we'll be splitting it that way.
So 18 tables of quads, instead
of one quad of whatever
this amount is-- eight by 16.
Not sure how many that is
off the top of my head.
But let's take a look at
swap0 in the distribution
so we can get a sense
of what we need to do
to begin implementing our Match 3 game.
Notice we have require
util for GenerateQuads.
We're just going to generate
for this basic example.
We're not going to differentiate between
colors, and varieties, or anything.
We're just going to put them all
into one quad, or one table of quads.
So we're just going to use the
regular GenerateQuads function.
We're not going to differentiate them.
We're just going to use our
sprite here, our match3.png
provided in the distro, which is
the exact same image that we just
saw on the screen.
I'm going to just generate them.
They're 32 by 32--
generate the quads for them.
They're 32 by 32 pixels.
I'm assigning it to a table
here called TileQuads.
And then here, we're
calling generateBoard,
and so generateBoard isn't all that
dissimilar to what we saw before
with maybe the level maker in Breakout,
where we just spawn a bunch of bricks,
or a bunch of tiles, in this case.
Except in this case, they're
kept in a nice 2D array that's
always going to be eight
by eight, and that's never
going to change just by one of
the constraints of the game.
Match 3, traditionally, is
an eight by eight grid that's
always full of tiles of some variety.
So local tiles, it's going
to be an empty table,
and then we're going to do
a nested for loop here--
y to x.
The standard is usually
y first, and then x,
and then we index y before x just
because the individual rows in a 2D
array, or sprite, or table will be such
that, for example, if our table was
equal to this-- oops, sorry.
Syntax bug.
If we did this, and then we have a table
here, and a table here, and a table
here, and we had like 0, 1, 1, 1,
1, 1, 1, 1, and then 1, 1, 1, 1.
If we index into this table--
so table at 0, that's going
to give us another table.
That's not going to give us--
let's say we wanted to get
the value at table 2, 3.
The instinct might be to think
I'm going to index at x, y
just because x, y tends
to be more commonly seen.
But if we did that, and
assumed that x was horizontal,
and y is vertical in this
arrangement, which is how we have it,
then table2 wouldn't be this value
here table2 would be this table here.
The first value you passed into indexing
some table when it's a nested table
is just, in fact, the
table itself, which
is why we actually need to do--
when we want to get some value,
we have to index at table y, x.
So it's flipped for that reason
because x is actually going to be--
the first index is going
to be these sub tables,
or sub arrays if you're in C,
or Java, or something like that.
So when you see table y, x, and
you're wondering why it's not table x,
y, that's the reason.
So any questions as to why
that is, or how that works?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SPEAKER 1: In this case, I
was using zero based indexing,
but Lua is one index.
That was just habit.
It was pointed out that I was using
zero based indexing in my example.
You want to use one based indexing
when you're actually programming,
and not zero based.
But the same principle applies.
Zero would be one in that case.
In a general purpose language--
most languages, if we were to abstract
the problem out in a C 2D array,
or C++, or Java, zero
would be appropriate there.
But anyways, we have a nested for loop.
We're starting at y, and
then we're going to x,
and then basically, that
has the effect of y,
and then x, x, x, x,
x, y, x, x, x, x, x.
Just insert a blank table.
Fill it with-- we're
just using tables here.
So we're not using any
sort of tile class,
or board class, or anything fancy.
We're just using raw data types here.
So we're just saying
insert into tiles y, which
by the way, if we're
at x equals 1, 8, here,
and we're in any given
iteration of our outer y loop,
tiles y will be the last
table that we just inserted--
the last blank table on the
first iteration of this x loop.
So basically, it's saying, in
the inner table that I just
put into the table that's going to
represent our board, the tiles table,
insert a new table.
So we have a table of tables of tables.
In the third table are the
actual tiles themselves.
You can think of this table as being
a tile data type, more or less.
Just implemented using a table.
That has an x-coordinate, a
y-coordinate, and then a tile,
and the tile is going to
be a random number that's
going to be the index into our quads.
So each tile holds x
and y, and then notice
that we're multiplying
by 32 because we're
going to use this to draw the tile, and
the tiles are 32 pixels tall by high--
sorry, wide by tall.
We are going to multiply
x minus 1, recall,
because even though tables are one
indexed, coordinates are zero indexed.
So x gets that times 32,
y gets that times 32,
and then get a random number
between 1, and the number of quads
in our tile quads table.
So recall this number sign here is just
a shorthand for length of the table,
and then we're going to return it.
So we generated our board.
It's a y by x grid of
table rows of little tables
that all have an x, y, and a tile
ID, and the tile ID maps to the quads
that we just generated.
OK, that's it for the init function.
Sorry, love.load in this example.
The love.draw uses a function called
drawBoard, and we pass in 128 by 16.
The 128 by 16 is just xy offsets.
We're just going to draw
our board at 128, 16,
and is it going to center our board.
And then if we go down
to drawBoard at line 89,
gets an offsetX, offsetY,
nested for loop again.
We're just iterating back
over the tiles that we got,
and recall, actually,
generateBoard returns tiles,
and then we set board equal to
the result of generateBoard.
So down here in line 89, again, in
drawBoard-- actually at line 95.
Within this nested for loop, we're
going to get a tile at board y, x,
just so we have a
shorthand reference for it.
We don't have to say board y, x several
times, which you would have to hear.
We're going to draw the sprite--
the quad at tile, tile,
tile.tile, which, recall,
is a random number
between one and whatever
the number of quads we have
in our tile quads table.
And then that x plus offsetX,
and the y plus the offsetY, which
has the effect of drawing every single
tile in our grid at some given offset.
And that has the result--
and I probably should have
run this, actually, in advance
just so I could illustrate it.
But we have a simple board.
Looks nice.
It's colorful, but
it's very, very basic.
Just a 2D render of our game.
There's no behavior or anything.
This is just how we draw the board.
So any questions as to how just the
drawing, and the creation of the board
work?
OK.
So swap1 is a little
bit more complicated.
It builds on what we
did before, what we just
built, which was getting the board
implemented, and drawn onto the screen.
But there's no behavior at all.
It's just a static--
basically, the same thing
as drawing an image onto the screen.
And so for that, what we want
to do is implement swapping.
So how do we think we
can accomplish this?
Anybody have any ideas
as to how we can swap?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] using tweening
to have it go in opposite directions.
SPEAKER 1: Well, we could.
That will have the effect of--
the response was we could use tweeting.
We could, and we
actually will for swap2,
but it's going to be a little
bit more complicated than that
because they're in a 2D array.
So if we just tween their x, y--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SPEAKER 1: They will be in
the same place in the array.
But yes, ultimate--
AUDIENCE: You could switch
the position in the array,
and then reload the array.
SPEAKER 1: Switch their position in
the array, and then reload the array.
We will switch the position.
We don't have to reload the array,
but we will switch their positions.
That's effectively, what it is.
Literally just take two
tiles, and swap in CS50,
where we just take two variables,
and get a temp variable that
points that one
variable, gets its values
while the second variable gets the
values of that one, or vise versa,
I think.
This one gets this one's values,
this one gets this one's values,
and then this one comes
down to this one, basically.
There's the middleman that keep--
because if this one gets this one's
values, it's going to get
overridden by this one's value.
So there would be no reference
to it's x, y, or anything.
So that's why you need to store this
one up here, so this one can come here,
and this and come back down here.
So we've done a swap, effectively.
And there's ways in Lua to
do swaps, as we saw before,
without even needing
a temporary variable.
You can just do xy get some other
xy, which sort of bypasses that.
But when you start to do four
things getting swapped at once,
and you have four commas, it can get a
little tricky, a little bit unwieldy.
I'm actually not 100% sure you can
unpack more than two things in Lua.
I'll have to double check on
that, but right off the gate,
we're seeing that double
assignment here on line 32,
highlighted x, highlighted y gets 1, 1.
And let me actually
run just so we can see.
There's actually a couple of
pieces here besides just that.
Swap1.
So we have the board
as before, we also have
something to show us where
to swipe because we have
to know where we're swapping the tiles.
In an ideal implementation, which is
an optional part of the assignment,
you would have mouse
behavior for your game.
So you could just click on two tiles,
or click, and drag, and swap them.
In this case, we're not doing that.
We're just implementing
key based behavior.
So when I press left, right,
up, or down, I can move.
If I press Enter on a tile, and then
move around, it's an indicator to me
that I've selected that tile
to swap with something else
because it needs to keep track of
OK, you want to swap this tile.
What do you want to swap it with?
I want to swap it with this tile.
So they get swapped.
Or this tile.
So you can swap it with
whatever tile you want to.
There's no constraints.
The actual distro code implements
a constraint, and so offhand,
what do you think a constraint would
be for making sure that we can't--
AUDIENCE: They have to be adjacent.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, they
have to be adjacent.
So what would that entail?
AUDIENCE: That their x [INAUDIBLE]
SPEAKER 1: Exactly.
And the shorthand for that, really,
is if the absolute value of their x's
minus their y's is equal to 1.
Because if you subtract
one's x from another one's x,
and then one's y from
another one's y, and then
you add the differences
together, that'll
tell you whether they're
directly adjacent to each other.
It has to equal one.
If equals zero, then their
x's and y's are the same.
If equals two, then it's two
tiles away on the x-axis,
or it's away on the x and the y, in
which case it would be diagonal to it.
So the only way is it's
x's minus it's x's.
Tile1.x minus tile2.x,
and tile1.y minus tile2.y,
if they're absolute value
of their difference is one,
then they're adjacent.
That's in the implementation.
So this is why we have these
variables here, highlighted tile.
Basically we're setting a flag
saying, do we have a highlighted tile?
If we do, we're going to perform some
drawing logic later down in the draw
function.
Basically, how would we draw a
highlighted tile, do you think?
AUDIENCE: Add a rectangle
with transparency.
SPEAKER 1: Exactly.
So the answer was add a
rectangle with transparency.
That's exactly what we do.
I'm going to go down to this part here.
So on line 173, if we
have a highlighted tile,
and basically, this is
in the middle of a loop--
our y, x before.
We've put it into a draw board.
We have the drawBoard
function, but x, y, or y, x,
the tile is going to be whatever
tile we're currently on,
and if we do have a highlighted
tile, and that tile's gridX--
notice we now have a new variable called
gridX, as opposed to it's regular x
so that we can check for these sorts of
things to see where it is in the array.
If it's gridX is equal to whatever
we've set highlightedX to,
and gridY is equal to highlightedY,
then love.graphics.setColor
half transparency, and then just
draw a rectangle with this 4
at the end of it, which actually
draws a rounded rectangle.
If you pass in no 4, it will
just draw straight rectangle,
but if you pass in an int at
the very end, that's how many
rounded segments basically
that rectangle will have.
So you can get rounded
corners on your rectangles,
and it's good for UI
drawing, and stuff like that.
We use it a little bit in the distro.
So that's how you get
a highlighted tile.
There was also a selected
tile, and a selected tile
is just draw a rectangle, same
thing, but it's a line this time,
and there's always going to be
a selected tile no matter what.
So we're always going to draw it here
at the end of our render function.
It's just 255--
234 for the opacity so that it's just
kind of transparent, but not super
transparent.
Set line width to 4 so that it's
not just a very thin rectangle.
If you set the line width, and then you
draw a rectangle with the line format--
the line mode of drawing, it will
use whatever the current line
width is when drawing the rectangle.
So we set it to 4, then draw
a line rect at selectedTile.x
plus offsetX selectedTile.y
offsetY, and we draw it 32 by 32
because that's the size
of a tile, and then
we set our color-- remember to always
set your color back to 255, 255, 255,
255 because if you don't, and I did
this when I was debugging, actually,
you get some fun stuff.
Wait, was that the right one?
Oh, I might have fixed
it up above where we--
there was an issue.
If you don't set, basically, your
color, and you set it to red,
everything will draw red
after you've done something.
So if it ever happens, remember to set
your color back to 255, 255, 255, 255,
anytime you change the color in
some way, like I'm doing here.
AUDIENCE: Alternatively,
you could also just
make sure to always set the color before
you draw something. is that right?
SPEAKER 1: Yes.
The response was make
sure you always set
the color before you draw something.
I think that's what I ended
up doing in this distro, which
is why it's not working anymore.
I think it was--
where was it?
It was here, but I must have
fixed it because I accidentally
left that out when I was debugging,
and it ended up drawing-- everything
was red.
So just as an aside just because
Love2D is a state machine.
Drawing it beforehand is
definitely the safer way to go too.
So the core of this, because we're
running a little low on time--
the core of this overall block
of code is just the swap here.
So if there is no highlighted
tile-- so basically,
if we pressed Enter or Return--
now, we have all input handling
in love.keypressed key.
And by the way, this is
input handling to change
the x and y of our selected tile.
If we press Enter, and we
don't have a highlighted tile,
then we need to have a highlighted
tile, otherwise we should swap them.
So we get a reference to tile one and
two, we swap, we create temp variables.
Recall, we need to have
that middle man up here that
keeps track of this tile's information.
So it's going to keep track
of all of tile2's information
with tempX, tempY, tempgridX,
and tempgridY because we
need to not only change
their x-coordinates,
but also their grid positions.
And then we need to
create a temp tile here.
Basically, here's where we actually
swap their places in the board.
So tile1.gridY, tile1.gridX gets tile2,
and then we're getting a reference
to temp tile so that we can--
because if we set board at
wherever tile1 is to tile2,
we won't have anything where tile2 is.
We need to have a temp
tile to keep track of--
sorry, we won't have anything at
tile1 if we overwrite it with tile2.
So we need a reference to tile1
here, so that we can put it
into where tile2's spot is, right here.
And then we need to do all that before
we end up swapping their coordinates
and tile grid positions, otherwise
you get weird buggy behavior
when you're moving the
selected tile around.
And then we can on the highlight,
and then reset our selection
because their selection is also going
to get changed after we do the swap.
So we need to put it to the second tile
because it gets swapped with whatever
tile we highlighted.
And that's the overall gist.
It's basically taking two
tiles, flipping the information,
storing a middleman.
Same thing in swap in CS50,
a little more complicated,
though because these all have subfields
that all need to get manipulated.
And a lot of this can actually
be done mathematically.
You can actually have its x
and y mathematically derived
from it's gridX and gridY.
Just multiply by 32.
In this case, I just kept them
as variables, and separate.
But yeah, you could just
do that too, and that
has the effect of swapping the
variables whenever we move them,
and then that's the fundamental
first step in Match 3,
is just swapping any two
tiles in a given position.
So does that make sense altogether?
OK.
So this example is actually not that
much different at all from swap2.
I'm going to show you swap 2 right now.
So if we go to swap2, the only
change we really have made
is that now tiles flipped instead
of instantly changing, they tween.
And this is a piece
of cake at this point.
We already know-- what's
the function we need to do?
Just timer.tween.
All we need to do is just
take the two, and then just
tween tile1.x and tile1.y
to tile2.x, and tile2.y,
and do the same thing in reverse.
Tween tile2.x, and tile2.y
to tile1.x, and tile1.y.
And so if we open up swap2, go
to main, nothing in this program
really changes, except in
update, where we go to line 99,
and we're just doing it here.
Notice the definition.
Over 0.2 seconds, it takes in
the definition table, here,
and it's taking in two entities
because we're modifying two things.
We're modifying tile2, and tile1.
We're just setting x to
tile1.x, and y to tile1.y,
and then tile1 is getting
the tempX and tempY
because before, it was just
getting it directly from the temp,
and now it's just tweening it over time.
But that was before just a
bunch of tile2.x equals tile1.x,
tile2.y equals tile2.y,
tile1.y equals tile2.y.
That's all it is.
That's what's really nice about it.
Now we don't have to
really work hard at all
to get nice, smooth
transitions in whatever we do,
whether it's a UI, or the game.
It's just super nice, and convenient.
So that's all we need to do
to get basic swapping done.
That was swap2, the tween swap.
And so I put together a
set of slides here just
to illustrate the algorithm that
we use to calculate the matches.
So right now we've got
swapping in, but we
don't know when we've gotten a match.
So just offhand, does anybody
have any idea as to maybe
how we can go about calculating
whether we've got any matches?
AUDIENCE: Well, we already figured out
how to track if a thing is adjacent.
So you, I guess, have
a table of adjacent--
you go through [INAUDIBLE] block,
and if you have an adjacent--
or for every adjacent block, you
check if that color equals your color.
And if it does, you check if--
well, then I guess you need to
figure out what direction it's in,
and then you check,
continuing in that direction,
if there's another of the same color.
SPEAKER 1: So their
response was when you're
looking at tiles, look
at all adjacent tiles,
and if there is a color that's the same
one, then figure out its direction,
and then move from there.
So like a recursive style.
I guess you could
implement it recursively.
It probably would be a little bit
trickier to understand, and probably
not as efficient.
The way that we are actually
going to implement it
is going to be a little
bit more iterative.
So all we really need to do is check
every row, and every column one time,
and then go basically, left to right.
So in this case, we have to
check every row and column one
time in this direction, and
then one time in this direction
because we can get vertical
and horizontal matches.
So we start off.
Let's just arbitrarily decide we want to
start going left to right down the data
structure.
So we'll go, what color is this?
That's brown.
OK, check the next one.
Is it the same color?
If it is, then say OK, the number of
matching tiles that we've found so far
is two.
If it's greater than
three, then later on we'll
need to add that group as a match
to our list of matches, basically.
But if it's not, OK, then the
number matches is one again.
So set it to one, and
then do the same thing.
Same color?
No.
OK, number of matches is one.
In this case, here we have the
number of matches is going to be two
because this is blue, and
then we're going to go ahead,
and then same color again.
The number matches is three, and then
we've gotten to the end of the row.
So we can say OK, what was
our last number of matches?
Was it greater than or equal to three?
If it was, add that group
of tiles to our table of
matches if we've gotten a
match, and then move on.
And we do that over, and over again,
and if it's in the middle of a group,
like it is here-- so this
isn't at the end of the row.
This is just in the middle of the row.
What we do is number of matches one,
two, three, and then we go here,
and it's set to one.
Well, first of all, we
check number of matches
when we get to a different color.
We say, OK, this isn't the
same color as this tile.
This is purple, and this is gray,
but number of matches is three.
So what we do is we just add
these three tiles to our--
we're keeping a table of matches
because we're going to go through,
and we're going to delete all of them.
And then, eventually, we're going
to do some tweening as well,
but we're going to delete all of these.
And then in order to do that,
we need to walk backwards.
We need to say, basically,
for x gets position
minus number of tiles in the
match, just add that to a match,
add that to a match,
and then add the match
to our table of matches.
And that's it for the x direction.
And for the y direction,
it's the exact same thing.
Going down here-- different color,
different color, different color,
different color, and then same
color, same color, different color,
but number of matches is three
because one, two, three, and then
it's going to walk backwards,
up to the top, add that match,
and then just continue down here.
Same thing, same thing,
and then same thing there.
This is at the end of the column.
So it's going to get to the end.
It's not actually going
to look for the next tile
because there are no more
tiles, but every time
we complete a row, or a column,
we check at the very end,
do we have the number of matches
equal to three or greater?
If we do, then we need
to do the same logic
as we did before by adding that
match to our list of matches.
So it's actually quite a simple
algorithm, and this is the set of steps
that I just illustrated.
We have a match found there.
Oh, sorry. [? Tony, ?] yes?
AUDIENCE: If you complete two
matches at once, would it see both?
SPEAKER 1: It would.
The question was if you complete two
matches at once, would it see both?
Yes.
If you complete-- and it
wouldn't if you deleted
them as you went because let's say
you had like one, two, three here.
I'm assuming that's what you mean,
one, two, three, one, two, three.
If you just deleted them as you
went, then no, it wouldn't see them.
It would go here, it would
get these three, delete them,
and then it would just see these two.
But because we walk
over the entire thing,
and then we only delete matches after
all of the matches have processed,
we're going to add this one first,
and then when we do our vertical one,
we're also going to see this one, and
so it's going to count as two matches.
And you could make your code a little
bit more complicated if you wanted to,
and say if there's an
intersection between two matches,
I want to give the player more points.
Or I want to give him some sort
of effect like in Candy Crush,
I think you get like
explosions, or Bejeweled,
you get explosions if
you get like a T pattern.
And if you get four in a row, you get
a laser or something across the screen.
And actually, part of
assignment is clear a row.
If you get four in a row, you
should clear that row, or call them.
If you do that, then
yeah, you can have logic.
But currently, all the distro does
is just this simple iteration--
horizontally, then vertically,
and adding matches as you go.
And actually, there is an
optimization that you can make.
If you go here, for example,
let's say we're going here, here,
and then we're here, and we're at a
different color than the last one.
We can just go to the next one.
We can just skip because we
know we only have two left.
There's no point in looking for a
match if you're at the n minus 2
because there's no possible
way to get a match.
So that's just a shortcut.
A little optimization you can make,
and that's actually in the code.
Just break off if you're at--
in the code, it's x or y equals 7.
Just break out of that
for loop basically,
and go to the next row, or column.
Any more questions as to how that works?
If you're actually looking in
the code, we won't go over it
in too much detail in class.
It's fairly straightforward,
I think, once I walk you
through the algorithm a little bit, but
I'll point you to the relevant lines.
It's in the play state.
No, sorry.
It's in the board in the
calculate matches function.
Here, on line 50, calculate matches.
So horizontal matches, y gets 1 to 8.
You keep a color to match,
and basically, you just
keep track of how many you've matched.
Match numbers one always when
you're doing a brand new color,
and then starting at x 2
to 8, because we already
got the first tile, basically, if the
color is the same, increment matchNum.
Otherwise, set our current color
to that color, the next tile.
If we've done this, and our match
is greater than or equal to 3,
then we found a match.
We can add a match.
We create a new table.
We go backwards from where we
are with x 2 gets x minus 1,
and then x minus matchNum.
So it works for no matter
how long the match is,
whether it's three, four, or five.
And then we're subtracting
1, and then you just
insert into that match, the
tile at that x 2 position
because the matches are made of tiles.
So a match is just a group
of tiles put together,
and so you can intersect to any given
match just by comparing the tiles,
and just seeing if they have
the same tiles, basically.
That's how you'd get a cross match.
And then after that's all done,
just insert into matches that match.
Here's a little optimization.
If x is greater than or equal to
7, and this is in part of the loop
where we already know that we're
on a new color from the last color,
we'll just break, and then set matchNum
to 1 if we haven't gotten to that point
yet.
And then this is the part of the
code that accounts for a last row--
the row ending with a match because
we're not going to be on the next loop
to see whether we're going
to a different color.
We just need to check to make sure
at the end of any row iteration,
or column iteration when we
go to the next row, or column.
Before we go to the next
row or column, that matchNum
is greater than or
equal to 3, and if so,
then do the same logic
here, but start x at 8.
And same thing for vertical matches.
Exact same logic, just
x and y are inverted.
And then that's it.
And then self.matches, we keep a
reference to self.matches in the board
so that later we can
remove them here, and I
believe we use it for something else.
And then we return, basically, if the
number of matches is greater than 0,
we're going to return matches, else
we're just going to return false.
And we can use this later.
We can say if matches
from our play state,
then we can call a few
other functions, and bring
in new tiles, and stuff like that.
But just for the sake of being
thorough as an illustration,
this is how the algorithm works.
In this case, actually, this was
before I made the optimization.
We wouldn't actually do this
in this particular case.
This would have shorted down to the
next column before it even checked this,
but if your algorithm didn't make
that optimization, then yeah,
I would just see two tiles there.
Go to the next one,
nothing there, no matches.
Same thing here.
There is a match there,
and the match would
be found not at the end
of the diagram here,
it would be calculated
when it's pointed here,
but it knows matchNum is greater
than or equal to 3 at that point.
And it does the exact same thing here.
We just go column wise,
and then nothing there,
nothing there, and then
we've got one right there.
And so the next part--
oh, any questions on
how that works at all?
The next part-- we have the matches now.
We have them in tables.
We have the tiles.
We have references to the tiles.
How do we remove the
tiles once we have--
how do we get rid of them as
soon as we have the matches?
Assuming that our board is a table, a 2D
table, and each array within there just
has a tile object, how would we
clear the board of our tiles?
AUDIENCE: Are you including what
you're shifting [INAUDIBLE]??
SPEAKER 1: No, just remove
it from-- just like like.
Just remove it from play.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
I guess you can [INAUDIBLE]
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, you could.
Yeah, with a little bit of
finagling, you could get it
to where you could set
a tile to be invisible,
and then you could just give
it a new tile ID, I guess,
and then shift it up above,
and then make it come.
Well, I don't know if
that approach necessarily
works super well for
this because of gravity
because the tiles have to come down.
So then you'd have to bring the lower
ones, if they were at the bottom here.
Those would have to come down.
That kind of approach
would be a little tricky.
You could make it work, I think.
The simple approach, which
we used in this distro,
is actually just setting them to nil
because if you set something to nil,
it's just not going to
render, in this case.
So we're just setting all of these
tiles that were previously there to nil.
They're nothing at this point.
They effectively would render like
this if you tried to render them,
assuming that your code accounted
for it, or it didn't break.
And then the next stage would be
the actual getting the board fixed
because we have the tiles removed.
So now, we have this
thing here, but there
is a step that has to happen before
we get new tiles, and that's gravity.
We have to actually
shift everything down.
So how do we go about
shifting tiles down?
So this first column, we don't
really have to do anything, right?
This column is all set,
but what about this column?
How would we shift?
How would we get that tile to go down?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SPEAKER 1: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Tweens again?
SPEAKER 1: Tweens.
Yes, we could do it with tweens,
but from a data structure
standpoint, how would we--
because that will just tween the
xy, but that won't necessarily
fix-- the underlying
data structure still
has to represent-- because we're
going to do iterations over it,
we have to have references to
the tiles in the right spots.
AUDIENCE: So just
shifting it was the table
from the fourth row to the fifth row.
SPEAKER 1: So how would you
start by getting this tile down
to this position?
AUDIENCE: Switching it from the
fourth row to the fifth row.
SPEAKER 1: You would.
How would your algorithm work step by
step to making sure that would happen?
AUDIENCE: Is it start from the bottom,
and if that's nil, it would go up more
SPEAKER 1: Exactly.
That's exactly you do.
You start from the bottom, and then
whenever we have anything that's nil,
we need to look for the first tile above
it that's not nil, and shift it down.
So in this case, we start from
the bottom, and we go up this way.
Not nil, not nil, not
nil, not nil, not nil.
So none of those are spaces in the code.
It's called spaceY, or space and spaceY.
So we go to the next
column over, and we only
have to check vertically in this case.
We don't have to do a
horizontal check for anything
because gravity can only
follow in one direction.
So we just go over here.
So we're only looping through this code,
effectively, in this case, five times,
but in our code, eight times.
But it needs to be a while
loop rather than a for loop,
and we'll see why in a second.
But start here.
We see oh, we have a space there.
So what we need to do is say,
OK, the lowest space is here.
So we need to look for the next
tile above it, and shift it down.
So we keep a reference to
this, and we look up here,
and we say oh, this is a tile.
Perfect.
So I'm just going to
take this tile, and I'm
going to set that space
index to that tile,
and then I'm going to
set this index to nil.
And then we just have to
start again, though, from here
because this tile is now space.
So we have to look up here, and
say OK, so basically, our y counter
stays at that thing, and then just goes
back up because our y counter could,
theoretically, come all the way
up here before it finds a tile,
and then shift it all the way down,
but we can't just-- or here, let's
say there are two tiles right here.
Our y counter might end up here
because these are all spaces,
and the tile gets shifted
down here, but we can't just
start our y counter back here
again, and go up to the next tile,
and look for spaces because we
have all these spaces down here.
So it's a while loop.
So while, basically, there are
no spaces on any of these points,
we need to make sure that
we keep lowering the tile.
So keep a reference here, tile
here, bring it down, space here.
So we keep a reference with space.
We say oh, there's a space here now.
We can look all the way up,
but there's no tiles anywhere.
So we know that we can just move
onto the next iteration of the loop.
We haven't found any tiles.
We don't need to bother with it.
Same thing here.
We have a space reference
here, tile, found a tile,
shift it down, space here, tile here,
shift it down, space, space, done,
and then we rinse, and repeat that.
It's kind of almost like a
bubble sort type of algorithm.
Not a sort, but it has the same sort of
look and behavior to it, more or less.
Here's just a visual illustration of it.
So start from the bottom, go up,
we're looking for spaces here.
No spaces; column is perfectly stable.
We found a space here, tile
is there, shift it down.
Restart the loop from the tile,
space, space, space, no more spaces;
column stable.
Space found, tile found, shift, space
found, tile found, shift, space found,
tile found, shift, and
so on, and so forth.
And so that's the gist.
Super, super basic.
But now we actually have
to replace the tiles.
AUDIENCE: You don't even need to check.
Once you shift a block
down, you don't even
need to check the space above
it, whether it's a space
or not because you know that's
automatically a space when you just
shifted a block, right?
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
Actually, that's true.
Yeah, I guess in that
case, you wouldn't need to.
But we do need a reference to that
space, and keep checking above it.
But yeah, I guess you probably
don't need, necessarily,
to check whether it's a space or not.
You can just assume it's a space, and
I actually think my code does that.
I'm not 100% sure off
the top of my head.
We can check, and see.
I think it's down here.
No?
Is it?
Oh no, it's in get falling tiles,
I think, which is on line 177.
So for 1 to 8 in x, we keep a spaceY.
So spaceY, we set it zero
because that's just a variable.
We don't have a space yet.
So just because you can't index a tile--
you can index Lua tables by zero,
but because they're not by default,
we're just setting the zero
as like our false space flag.
y gets 8, starting at the bottom.
So while y is greater than or equal
to 1, tile gets self.tiles y of x.
In that case, it's going to
be at the eighth position.
So space is set to false,
but space is our space
found flag, and also whether or
not the tile that we just looked at
was a space.
Sorry, no, it's just our space flag.
We check to see if there is a
tile at our current position.
So recall, everything gets set to nil.
So we can just say local
tile gets self.tiles y x.
This will be nil if
there was no tile there.
So if tile, which means if it's not
nil, if it equal something, spaceY of x
is going to equal that tile.
We keep a reference to spaceY,
which is our last space.
We set tile.gridY to spaceY because
we have to reset it to gridY.
We're going to tween it here.
This is how we actually get
the falling, tweening behavior.
We're going to tween it's y to
tile.gridY minus 1 times 32,
recall, because coordinates are zero
based, but Lua tables are one indexed.
Space is false, y is spaceY,
and then spaceY gets zero.
Basically, we're going to start at the--
we're going to put spaceY
to that tile, and then we're
going to set spaceY to 0.
I think it actually does, in this
case, it is actually checking that tile
to make sure that it's--
yeah, because it's just
getting set to the tile--
spaceY being the tile that we
just replaced, and just put
into an actual spot.
So it does actually make the check up
above to see whether that's a space
or not.
Only one caveat though actually is--
actually, no, that wouldn't be true.
I was going to say, if you're
at the top of the screen,
but no because there's no way we
can be at the top of the screen,
and have-- yeah, I don't
think it would work.
A small optimization you could make
is you just assume always a space.
Yeah.
That's the get falling
tiles in a nut shell,
or at least the ones that
are falling from gravity.
And then we also have tiles that
we want to add to replace them,
and so we'll see that here.
So this code.
So what we need to do to replace--
what do you guys think we need
to do to get replacement tiles?
AUDIENCE: Check response, and
check if it's empty, [INAUDIBLE]
but if it's not, then you're done.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, exactly.
So the response was
check to see from the top
if there are any tiles that
are empty, and if there are,
then spawn some tiles, and then ideally,
tween them to their new positions.
You can basically just assign
them to their values here.
So what we need to do,
actually, though, is
if we spawn a tile up here to put into
any of these positions, their gridY's
need to be set in
advance because they're
going to occupy that space anyway.
Their actual y position
needs to be tweened.
So because the x and the y are
separate from the gridY, and the gridX,
those are just table indices,
but not their coordinates.
We can tween those,
and it won't actually
have any effect on the data structure.
The data structure itself can maintain--
we can still use the data structure--
put a tile in its right
spot in our table,
and then give it the right gridX, and
gridY, but tween the x and y value.
We can do whatever we want with those.
We can make them spin
around, and stuff as long
as the data structure
is intact, and ideally,
as long as we can't input
while it's doing it's movement,
and stuff like that because that
could create some visual bugs.
And so what we do is we actually disable
input when a swap is taking place,
and you'll see that in
the distribution code.
But yes, count how
many spaces there are.
Spawn four tiles, spawn
two tiles, spawn two tiles
spawn four tiles that have already
been given their right gridX, gridY,
and then just tween their y
to wherever it needs to go.
It's gridY times 32--
gridY minus 1 times 32.
And so that's what we're doing here.
We're just count, and then boop.
That was my favorite part of
putting this show together.
And so we're going to get into a couple
of minutes of talking about sprites,
and palettes, but I
think the one thing--
blanking for a second.
I was going to talk
about one last thing.
Let me see if I can
figure out what that was.
Oh, right, so in the board--
sorry, in the play state, I believe,
is where this is, there is a function.
So play state has it's own
calculateMatches, basically,
where it waits for you to--
where once you've basically
swapped any two tiles,
it will calculate whether
those tiles have made a match.
And we're going to get matches
via self.board calculateMatches,
the function that we
were looking at before.
If there are any matches--
well, we play a sound
effect here for every match.
This is where you also
calculate the score.
You just multiply the number
of tiles in a match by 50,
and part of the assignment
will be adding some value
to the individual
varieties of the tiles.
Here, we tween.
So we return also from
the board class a table
of tweens for all of the new
tiles that we just spawned,
and so what we're going to end up
doing is tweening all of them here.
So notice that we're
passing in a timer.tween,
this variable, tilesToFall.
That's a definition file that we're
just returning from our board class.
And so once those are all
finished, then we get new tiles,
and then we tween here.
I think this line is
redundant, actually.
I think this might have
been a debugging line.
I don't think we need this.
No, we don't need this at all.
So sorry.
This is the important part.
We're going to tween--
wait, we do need it.
Self.board getNewTiles.
What am I thinking of?
Sorry, a little bit
confused for a second.
I thought this was an empty
function that I defined.
Get new tiles.
Yeah, this returns an empty table.
But basically, the
gist of it is the play
state, when it calls this function,
it will call itself every time.
And I think this is actually
having the result of doing it
instantly here because newTiles
is just an empty table.
I think all this should be is just
this inside all of this like that.
But that has the result
of calling itself again
because when we get new tiles
coming from the top of the screen,
we could potentially have a case
where we've gotten some matches,
and it's not shown here, but new
falling tiles could give us new matches.
So after we calculate matches, let's
say maybe this tile dropped here,
but it was a purple, and
these two were already there.
We've already calculated
matches, but then we
need to do it again, and then do
it again if it keeps happening.
And so you should be recursively
call self calculateMatches
in that case, which will have the effect
of accomplishing that because this
will always look for matches.
And so when we call self
calculateMatches here, over, and over
again, until there are no matches--
as long as there are matches,
this should keep happening.
You should keep getting scores, and
tiles should keep getting cleared.
But as soon as that's
not the case anymore,
then self.canInput equals true, and
we're not calculating matches anymore.
We don't recursively call the
function anymore, and we're done.
And so that's just the point
I wanted to illustrate.
Got slightly confused by, I think,
what was a vestige of my old code.
Maybe I was trying something,
but I think this, ultimately,
should just be this, and I'll test
it, and make sure, and then push
the change.
And it doesn't need to
be over 0.25 seconds.
It can just be instant.
Palettes, really quickly, with
something I wanted to cover,
which was just the idea of
taking art, and then just-- and I
have a couple of cool examples to show.
Just taking some sort of
picture, and then giving it--
only using or some sort of image,
and only using 32, in this case,
or some arbitrary number of colors.
This is some fancy stuff that some
person named DawnBringer online did.
He generated a very famous 32 color
palette called DawnBringer's 32 color
palette.
But basically, it allows--
this is done with just 32
colors we see on the screen.
Those are all dithered.
Dithering is a term which means to
just draw two colors pixel by pixel,
interleaved, so that from far away
it looks like a brand new color,
and this is a dithering chart.
This just shows you every
color here at the very top.
These are all 32 colors.
These are 32, and those are 32
intersected with each other such
that they're just like
dot, dot, dot, dot, dot.
Every other dot is every other color.
And so you can do some pretty amazing
things with just a few colors.
This is actually done with 16 colors.
All four of those are only 16 colors.
This is just to show you what it looks
like when you do it to an actual image.
This is an example of what using
a color palette on an image that
doesn't work well with it looks like.
So this is a regular
image with I don't know
how many colors, thousands of
millions of colors, and this
is using DawnBringer's 32 color palette.
So still looks very
similar to what it should.
It's a cat, but there's a lot of weird
things going on in the background
because taking an image with a lot of
blur, and a lot of distorted color,
has the effect of giving you
blotchy patterns when you go down
to a few colors.
But this is an example of an image
that has a lot of flatter colors.
There's still a lot of
colors in this image.
There are some shades, and stuff like
that, but this is thousands of colors,
and this is 32 colors.
So clearly, if you do
it on the right thing,
you can actually get really
good effects with it.
And so again, not a whole lot
of difference, but this one's
got I don't know how many
hundreds of thousands of colors,
and this one's only got 32.
And so how it ties back
into what we're doing
is this is using a 32-bit color
or 32 color palette on purpose.
This is actually DawnBringer's
32 color palette.
Breakout used the same
palette, 32 colors,
and a lot of our 2D future lectures
will use limited color palettes.
If you're trying to draw sprite art, and
you want some quick, and easy ways just
to give your work a
little bit of consistency,
I recommend trying to pick
8, or 16, or 32 colors,
and just adhering to using just those.
And you'd be surprised
at how much you get out
of it, and how much more
cohesive your work will look just
by imposing that constraint on you.
It's an artifact of a real world
constraint of former hardware.
The NES only had so many colors
it could color each sprite,
like four colors, or something that.
And so you also get a-- if you're
going for an authentic retro look,
it will help you in that sense.
And then different from
palettes, but related
is palette swapping, which is
another term you've probably heard,
which is basically all
of these Mario sprites--
they'll probably start with a gray
scale Mario, some like gray version
where each of these separate
colors are mapped out
to some table where one equals
red, two equals blue, or whatever.
And then you can just shift
all of them, and then you
get all of these different
nice effects, assuming
that you've created a good palette.
You can get a lot of
reuse, and this is actually
how Super Mario Bros. used to
do some of its programming.
The clouds and the bushes
were the same sprite.
One was just colored green.
It was palette swapped green from
the white that the cloud was colored.
So that's the gist of Match 3.
Assignment 3 is going to
have a few parts to it.
So time addition on matches.
So when you get a match, you
should get time added to the clock.
Currently, right now,
you only get 60 seconds.
It's a little bit hard to actually
get past level two at this point.
So getting points for
every tile in a match.
Make it so that level one
starts with simple flat blocks.
So earlier, we saw the
array of tiles, and it
was flat tiles on the first
index of every color row,
but there were several other patterns
like x's, and circles, and triangles,
and stuff.
Make those worth some higher
amount of value, each one.
Create random shiny variants of blocks
that will destroy an entire row when
you get a match.
So have a block.
It should have some
field, shiny or something.
If it's shiny, render it with
something to make it look shiny.
You can use particle effect if you want.
You can put a very opaque, or a very
transparent maybe yellowish or whitish
rectangle on it to give
it a brighter look.
And then if it's in a
match, that entire row
should get cleared instead
of just that match.
Only allow swapping when
it results in a match.
This is an important thing
because right now, mathematically,
it's actually very unlikely
that you'll get a board that
has matches on it to begin with.
So you're going to have to pick a
subset of tiles in your implementation,
and actually use those instead
of just using all of them.
Pick six tiles, which you can get
variants on, or just whatever flat
colors, and then use only
those to spawn your board.
Don't use all 18, or
however many there are.
And then optional, if you're
curious, if you want, probably,
an arguably better gaming
experience with this,
just implement actually
playing with the mouse.
Being able to click and drag,
or just click individual tiles.
And to do that, you
will need to convert--
because we use the push
library for virtual resolution,
you'll need to convert the
window mouse coordinates
to push coordinates so that they'll
map into the game space appropriately,
and so you'll use a function
called push to game, where
it takes an x and y, where the x and
the y will be your mouse coordinates.
Next time, we're actually
going to get into a little bit
more robust of a game,
arguably, like a Mario clone.
This is actually where
this course started
was I taught a seminar
on Super Mario Bros.
We won't be using Super Mario
Bros. assets because of copyright,
but we'll be using this tile
sheet here, which is very similar.
It's got a nice aesthetic.
We'll cover tile maps.
So how to generate levels
using individual tiles.
2D animation, so rather
than just like static things
that we've had going on so far, you'll
have characters that actually walk,
and jump, and do different things.
We'll talk about how
to actually procedure
generate platformer levels,
which isn't terribly difficult.
It sounds kind of difficult,
but it's actually pretty--
for very simple stuff, it's not too bad.
Basic platformer physics, so
hitting blocks, and jumping,
and stuff like that.
We've covered a lot of that with
Flappy Bird, actually, and actually,
the bricks from Breakout kind
of tie into it a little bit.
Hurt boxes so we can have enemies
that hurt you, and visa versa.
And power ups so that you can change
your state in some way to make you
larger, or invincible, or whatnot.
That was Match 3.
Thanks a lot, and see you next time.